schwere waffen seit monaten fordert die
ukraine sie von deutschland seit wochen
hat deutschland sie versprochen und
jetzt sind die ersten tatsächlich da der
ukrainische verteidigungsminister
respekt bedankte sich heute auf twitter
bei
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht dass die panzerhaubitze 2000
zitat endlich in der ukraine
einsatzbereit sei und weiter unsere
artilleristen werden damit auf dem
schlachtfeld einheizen das schrieb der
verteidigungsminister martialisch mit
noch drei feuer images dahinter die wir
live zu unserem reporter in der ukraine
zu paul ronzheimer paul ja also die
ersten schweren waffen tatsächlich
angekommen man hatte schon nicht mehr so
richtig daran geglaubt gibt schon erste
reaktionen außerdem feuer es aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
was sich aus der ukrainischen regierung
und auch hier vor ort im donbass führer
ist dass man glücklich darüber ist dass
das jetzt endlich was passiert ist aber
viele menschen stellen sich die frage
kommen die zu spät denn hier wo ich
gerade stehe wenige kilometer von hier
entfernt da rücken die russischen
truppen gnadenlos vor thomas ja es soll
noch mehr waffen kommen und zum ersten
mal paul hat die bundesregierung auch
die bislang geheim gehaltene liste
veröffentlicht mit den waffen und
ausrüstungen die deutschland bisher in
die ukraine geliefert hat wir schauen da
mal kurz rein also zum beispiel die
panzerhaubitzen das haben wir
vorhergesehen aber auch fast 15.000
panzer abwehrend mit abwärme flieger
abwehrraketen flieger fäuste 16
millionen schuss hand waffen munition
100 1000 meter springt nur und dazu auch
viele neue ausrüstungsgegenstände das
geht von krankenhausbetten über
schlafsäcke bis hin zu laser
entfernungsmesser also da ist schon
einiges geliefert worden und es kommt ja
auch noch etwas
die frage aber eben paul di do
aufgeworfen hast kommt es zu spät
schilder uns doch die aktuelle situation
dort im don bosco bürst
die russen drohen den gesamten bereich
lukas komplett einzukesseln da sind nur
noch vier prozent ungefähr die in
ukrainischer hand sind putin will
offenbar diese woche noch lukas diese
region komplett erobern die umkämpften
städte sind weiterhin stato netz und
nikita und warum gewinnen die russen
dort thomas du hast gerade diese lange
liste angesprochen aber den ukrainern
bringen diese panzerabwehrwaffen die man
in kiew zum beispiel im kampf im februar
mehr zu gebrauchen konnte weil das
häuserkampf war die helfen hier nicht
wirklich denn russland hat die taktik
umgestellt sie machen mit der artillerie
alles platz und erst dann rücken sie vor
und die ukraine konnten bislang kaum
zurück schlagen weil sie nicht so viele
artillerie haben nicht so viel
artillerie haben wie die russen und vor
allem in die munition ausgeht die
panzerhaubitze das ist das worauf sie
gewartet haben davon bräuchten sie aber
noch viel mehr die frontlinie 1500
kilometer lang das konzentriert sich
zwar auf einen kleineren bereich aber
auch da sind rund 5 panzerhaubitzen von
denen man spricht zwar etwas aber
sicherlich kein game changer thomas
sommer mit der aktuellen einschätzung
vielen dank danke paul
[Applaus]